our lives have been taken over by
screens you know yesterday I saw a chart
that somebody posted on Twitter when I
was staring at my own screen showing how
the U.S birth rate has declined by 20
since 2007. really it if you look at the
chart if the birth rate was was rising
and then you hit 2007 and it just hits
uh it's like diving off a cliff well
guess what else happened in 2007 the
first smartphone was released I don't
think that's a coincidence the
proliferation of screens and along with
it pornography social media everything
else has impacted every facet of Our
Lives to a degree that we will likely
never completely understand and this has
also impacted our quote unquote mental
health and certainly not in a good way
people are reporting feeling isolated
and lonely and all these things because
increasingly we are because our lives
revolve around these screens